hey I'm John Mayer and we are in
hollywood california today shooting a
very high tech new tech video for a song
called heartbreak warfare
I've never actually done the green
screen thank you for it really is as
thankless as they say remember that
number that little city did right there
that little little tribunal up there is
sitting right there like this we're
gonna go to end or go to enjoy it's cool
every once in a while look up at the
camera or just kind of glance over your
shoulder like the screen every what's
wrong nice i gotta trust with that what
the directors saying hey got down to
your side and pick it up my start with
the note baddest down on the couch it's
it's very cool something called
augmented reality which is a sort of
like a digital hologram based off of a
marker set graphic that the camera of
your computer recognizes and manipulates
visuals off of the marker depending on
where you're holding it and where it is
in proximity to the to the lens on the
camera on the computer and how you're
turning it so it's very exciting it's
like a completely 3d immersive
experience that you have it starts out I
am as always pensive and thoughtful in
my room which I hardly ever
a pensive and thoughtful and writing the
song and thinking about it so it's sort
of moving from this very sort of like
casual guy in a room and then come there
into the sort of middle of the song
where I transition into being on a
battlefield and keeping with the
heartbreak warfare battlefield theme I
end up sort of entering this really cool
otherworldly universe of falling bombs
and bright colors and things just
stemming and growing and blossoming and
blooming so I won't know what we've got
until until they run it through their
newfangled computers
I'll be the first musician in a video
centered around this new technology so I
won't be the 12th like I used to
transition from there to like putting
maybe a one of your feet underneath your
other like you're sitting on your foot I
have a penis sorry buddy